So a lot is being written and said about
deep learning and the new ai wave and
not everything is true.
So yes,
one of the things that's natural,
so the idea that machines program
themselves these days and all the have
to do is put mediocre data in turn the
crank and outcome excellent results.
But that is um,
but I think of true magic in this deep
learning and here's what really
fascinates me the most about this field
is a deep learning led's or solve
problems.
We don't know how to program so we can
solve problems.
We actually don't understand in detail
sophia in sufficient detail that we can
program a solution.
The first time I witnessed this is quite
awhile ago,
it was around 1992 I was in at eth in
Switzerland working on a reading machine
for the blind and we made good progress
on printed texts.
But we,
when we,
we got nowhere for handwritten text.
And so I was reading through paper after
paper was promising titles and just to
be disappointed time and again.
So most people back then they worked on
capitol letters from eight to f for
example,
that tiny variations to the bitmap and
10 called it Fontin variant.
And then somebody pointed me to the work
of Yonder coon and I looked into that
and was very fascinated because he was
working with actual data from the u s
postal service,
no,
no cheating possible.
And he claimed to have excellent
results.
And he's methods we are comparatively
simple.
So we rushed to re implementers and well
first we had to rush to actually collect
data and then train the network and it
felt like magic it,
it would actually read and do this
seemingly impossible task.
So a year later I was fortunate to join
that very team at bell labs.
So I divided my presentation into two
parts.
The first part I will talk about the
early uh,
deep learning work at bell labs.
And then the second part I will talk
about our current vogue at Nvidia on
self driving cars.
So from 1990 from 1985 to 90 1995 was a
10 year period.
It was incredibly productive.
So in that team,
that team not only created convolutional
networks,
uh,
it also created support vector machines
as vms and later foundation of
important,
uh,
machine learning,
learning theory,
and also,
uh,
created several generations of neural
network.
Okay.
This is the building in homedale new
Chelsea.
So gigantic building,
actually a t eight house,
about 6,000
employees,
300 of those were in research and 30 of
those in machine learning.
So you'll probably recognize several of
the names.
Um,
and since as researchers we tended to
show up late in the day,
we always had to park way out here,
which added about 10 more minutes to
your commute just to walk into the
building and into your office.
There's these two ponds here.
Uh,
could you imagine what they are for?
They're not just landscaping.
Yeah,
yeah.
They thought that he takes changes for
the,
for the air conditioning of the building
or it used to be late today,
replaced them with cooling towers.
This is the very first data sets that
I've worked with,
uh,
collected among the researchers
themselves.
A later they got data from the U S
Postal Service.
Um,
and then that grew into nist and nist,
which is still very widely used today.
So a lot of the work was about what
structure to be put into the learning
machines.
What prior knowledge do we equip them
with to,
to perform the task?
Well,
um,
if you talk about,
if you look at this example here and you
needed to build a classifier that can
distinguish between the red and the
green classes and you wonder what class
does this x belong to?
So if you take,
um,
location east,
west,
north,
south as you criteria to classify,
then you would probably say the x
belongs to Green.
But if you understand that these points
are actually real points on the surface
of the earth and it happens that the
green ones are on board and the red ones
are on land,
then you could change your criteria and
say,
let me take a level above the height,
above sea level as the criteria,
in which case the problem becomes
trivial.
So this point is actually on land.
So he belongs to the right class.
Anybody see that?
He sees
this is Manhattan,
New York.
So this is an example how programming or
are using prior knowledge actually helps
the classification task enormously.
Um,
of course that led to the creation of
convolutional networks.
This is an old slide that we use to
explain how they work.
Naturally you have these convolutions
that can learn to do,
um,
today's lines,
vertical,
horizontal,
and then next layer can the deck at and
so on.
And of course the leap of faith was that
we don't have design these features,
but actually like a numerical
optimization algorithm find optimal
solutions.
Oh,
he has an old video from yonder coon
showing low net.
Yeah,
you supposed to own an old 80 and tpc I
believe was a dsp accelerator in it.
So yeah,
you may have seen the video.
It's,
it's on youtube and at that time,
many,
many brilliant minds tried so hard for
years to solve the problem.
And here comes,
this network can just does it was almost
looks with ease.
Then young gets creative.
I'm quite sure that this type of
characters,
we're not in the training side.
Some other people from the lab.
This is Donnie Henderson,
a three child who was the lab director
at the time.
So as we became to look at,
learning is essentially two main things,
monies to build prior knowledge into the
architecture of what Vladimir about
calls,
structural risk minimization.
And the other one is a capacity control.
So you need to match the size of your
network to the amount of diversity of
the data that you have and one really
good tool to do that or to to analyze
that these learning curves.
So this is not the number of epochs he
otis a actually each point on this chart
is a fully trained network.
So what do you do is you measure the
performance of your network on the
training set and on the test track while
you're growing the and not the amount of
data that you're training the network
with.
So this is the,
uh,
the number of examples that you use for
training.
So if you have very,
very few examples,
then the networks can essentially
memorized a training set and the ad or
on the training side is zero.
While the error on the test that is very
big.
And then as you grow the Dataset,
the,
uh,
error on the test that calms down and at
some point the networks can no longer
memorize and that the entire data set
and the,
the training said Arrow starts to grow.
And empirically it's been shown that
these curves eventually die neat.
And you don't need to plot the entire
curve.
It's usually in the middle between the
two curves.
So you can half a good idea what to
expect.
So if you hit this point a year,
then it becomes clear that it doesn't
help you to add more data.
You have to increase the capacity of
your network.
Uh,
he has a learning curve from real life
that we did last week.
So this is,
uh,
here,
predicting the steering angle of a
human.
So how close does the netbook steer like
a human?
And you see that,
uh,
around here we reached a point where
adding new data wouldn't help us.
Then in the 90s,
[inaudible] was sometimes heated debate
about what is the best algorithm for
classifying characters.
And
the,
uh,
manager of the group at the time was
Larry Charcoal.
And he said,
well,
let's just find out and combat all of
those.
So this was one of these ideal
situations.
Very had several people competing with
ideas and everybody was convinced my
idea is the best.
Um,
so I'll be combined them all and if I
remember correctly,
that's what,
that's the reason that they created the
nist database for.
So m stands for modified
the result is somewhat interesting.
So,
um,
k nearest neighbor that nobody believed
that that would be the winner.
Um,
that was just there for reference.
Also fully connected network.
They're just there for reference.
Then this is lanette one.
This was optimized for a much smaller
data set from the United States postal
survey.
So that didn't do very well on this
either.
In fact,
it was even slightly versed and fully
connected.
And then these here,
these were the actual competitor.
So this is a convolutional network,
but this time optimized for the lots are
mds data set.
Uh,
I'll get back to boosting in a minute.
Then different variations.
Um,
so he,
uh,
for example,
k nearest neighbor of course,
has one big flaw.
So if you'd just take the Euclidean
distance,
um,
as your metric as we did here,
then if you shift to characters which
are actually the same by a few pixels,
then the Euclidean distance starts to
become enormous.
So it doesn't really measure how close
to our house similar to characters are
very well.
So here,
the idea of stop lights instead of using
the Euclidean distance,
let's do the same thing.
I'm used the EUCLIDEAN distance,
but not in the pixel space,
but in the uppermost feature map.
And that's a boost.
It's the performance quiet a bit.
Tangent distance was another one of the
ideas we talked a lot at a time.
Uh,
another clever trick to increase the
performance of k nearest neighbor.
So if you'll picture each character to
be a point in a very high dimensional
pixel space and you start doing some
photo probations to eight without
changing the actual characters.
So you,
you rotate it all it a little bit,
you shifted,
you grow the stroke a bit,
um,
then that forms a surface around that
point.
And if you don't deviate too much from
the original point,
and you can model that as a plane.
And the tangent reasons is simply the
EUCLIDEAN distance between two such
planes.
I'm so clever idea was a lot of prior
knowledge of the problem built into and
that also gets very good performance and
optimal margin.
That's essentially an Svm.
And so what's interesting is that they
all have the exact same performance.
The only one that actually improve the
performance was boosting,
which is kind of a different type of
approach.
So here you train multiple networks,
you're trying to second network on the
mistakes of the first one and your
trainers.
Third one on there,
the first to disagree.
So you get multiple expert.
I specialize on different parts of it,
of the training sentence.
So it's not too surprising that that
actually would increase the performance.
So what Larry said in hindsight is that,
well,
it's not too surprising that I would all
perform the same because everybody was
doing the same type of approach in
exploring them the past capacity of
their learning system by doing the
learning curves.
The one thing that stands out in my mind
is the Svm because that has no prior
built in knowledge about the task at
all.
But all of the others too.
Um,
classification rate is not the only
thing that you should actually focus on.
Of course,
it's also memory consumption,
which is not on this chart,
a training time and inference time.
So all of the memory based k nearest
neighbor types,
they use very little training time,
but then they use a lot of memory.
So the lessons,
some of the lessons that I took from
that time is,
uh,
one is still very relevant,
is look at the data.
I've seen so many people miss important
cues.
I'm confused why you we was Rgb,
for example.
That doesn't make your system failed
completely.
It just doesn't perform as well as he
could.
Um,
solid debugging tools are critical.
These a neural networks have a nasty
habit of a masking box and the they and
I adapted a,
they try their best to work around
parks,
um,
validated training data.
Again that's related to look at the
data.
Um,
so many data sets I've seen actually
have a grave labeling mistakes and to
work is experimental in nature.
At least that's what it is to stay off
today.
So in most cases you can just copy paste
or recipe from somebody else that will
now give you the optimal results.
And the last one is work with real data.
Synthetic data is great for debugging
and you can certainly explore certain
trends,
but to get a sense of very,
you really are,
um,
you,
you have to work with real data.
So what happened after 95,
actually riding around the 95,
uh,
a t and t released a first production
version of convolutional networks for
commercial check reading.
And eventually 20% of all the checks
written in the u s were processed by
that system or right by that system.
To me,
that was the real,
the real sign of success.
If a technology is a commercially buy
apple at the set in the same year
actually,
um,
maybe in the morning sitting together
discussing how we should celebrate this
fact.
The success was the commercial check
reading and a message came in that day.
T and t d announcement came in at eight
and t would break up into three parts.
So that was quite a shock.
And then in 2002,
there were mass layoffs and most people
left.
And some of the important folks from
machine learning,
they found themselves working together
again,
either add star power or for Darpa and
created several programs such as locker
learning,
applied to ground robots,
uh,
learning locomotion.
One was even called deep learning and
also the helping to get about his
difference.
Darpa challenges launched.
And then in 2002 deep learning becomes
really popular and I guess it's
triggered by the availability of data,
the availability of compute powers and
also,
uh,
ready commercial applications.
So all of these large scale internet
applications in speech recognition and
image classification,
they bill radio at this point.
And I guess there was just not too much
money in check rating for the economy to
take notice back then.
So this brings me to what you're doing
today.
Very similar technology applied to a
self driving costs in this case.
So felleston over the off the entire
stack of and be yourself driving.
So we have at the bottom the hardware
that goes into the car,
that's the drive px family of products.
The most recent is called Pegasus.
That was just announced at ces.
Then we have the operating system or the
old timer,
but I think system layer.
And then on top of that is driver folks.
That's what I call the middle man.
So that does sensor abstraction does a,
all the logging tools interprocess
communication and it has low level
computer division library such as image
transformations.
And then on top of that is a drive a,
b.
This is the application.
Yeah.
So this is where it would be put
together all of the other technology to
form actual applications.
And some examples are here.
This is um,
sensor fusion from radar and camera on
this,
this lidar point cloud processing or
deep learning based object detector.
So the detective boss here,
or to pedestrians back there.
This is deep learning based,
uh,
pre risk-based.
That action.
Um,
this is localization based on hd maps
and then this year is a perception based
as a planning.
This is actually what comes out of our
group in New Jersey.
So what a new Chelsea group is doing
there,
we contribute into this layer here
and our goal is to solve the heart and
on solves problems.
And I think there's a lot of those in
self driving car.
So if I think back to a character
recognition,
if we can't even program handwritten
character recognition,
then it's very likely that dealing with
other humans and all kinds of different
situations is likely not going to be
solvable by just programming.
So we concentrate on these heart
problems for two reasons.
One is that we want to provide
algorithmic diversity.
So in a safety critical system,
it's unlikely that you want to rely on
any single algorithm.
And the second reason is that we can
solve functionality that might not be
solvable otherwise.
Like,
uh,
taking turns just based on perception
without map data or learn to march on to
a busy highway where you have to
negotiate with the other cars and
squeeze yourself in.
And then other,
the other labs,
um,
the other autonomous labs in a Nvidia
are in California,
in Boulder,
in Seattle,
and in Europe.
This is,
oh,
we're actually back in the same
building,
which is cool.
The building was empty for over 10
years,
but it's now being redeveloped for mixed
use.
So there's a number of different tech
tech companies in there.
So in Eto is renting space around here
and there's also,
we're going to get restaurants and shops
and on the rooftop test plans to build a
hotel.
Uh,
the reason why the tear is,
um,
not so much sentimental.
It's because this is actually a very
good environment for testing,
self driving cars.
We have plenty of space in the basement
of the building to store and welcome to
cars.
And then there's two tunnels here.
Then with that we can take and dare
leaders right up to these private
routes.
Here on the campus.
Driving Monster around here is actually
two miles.
And then right outside we have a very
nice mix of highway local adults in the
residential adults.
The location is also quite
nice.
Um,
so I've got about 45 miles from New York
City and there's a train connection and
fairy.
So the train is about 60 to 70 minutes
and to failures faster actually can take
the shortcut.
So it's around 40 minutes.
So
what is a typical case where rule based
system struggle?
While this seems clear so they can
detect these lane markings,
localize the car within it and then half
a past planner and the controller and
thrive,
but just um,
about a hundred meters further up on
this road to situation looks like this.
So it's much harder now.
So he can just,
you have to double yellow line,
marker fainted and then the center one
is almost gone.
You can still solve it.
Of course you can build a detector for
this curb.
But offense,
you may be able to reconstruct these
yellow lane marking.
Then you can measure the distance here
and decide that this is actually buy it
at an online.
This is probably two lines and I'm
currently here,
so I'm going to assume that there's
actually a virtual lane here and I'm
going to drive down.
And then you have solved the problem for
tastes for it is a scenario and then
around the corner it's different again.
So you have to start all over.
And then again and again.
So it seems a big advantage if we can
build a system that can derive to domain
knowledge from data.
So by just observing humans,
not by somebody telling it what it
actually should look for in this scene.
So what we,
this is one of the things that we built.
Um,
if this is the line here,
that's where the car currently is,
then we predict there would the human
drive.
So what is the short term trajectory
that the human will take given that
image?
And so collecting the data is relatively
simple.
You just drive,
um,
you can then derive this trajectory from
the IGA motion of the car.
So that training labels,
you essentially collect them for free
without additional manual labor while
you're collecting the data.
And so then the,
the difference between what a human
drove and what the network predicts,
that's the Arrow signal that we back
propagate.
Uh,
this is an example network architecture.
Um,
this is from about two years ago.
It still looks similar but it's growing.
So we constantly adapting to the,
to the current size of the training
side.
Oh yeah.
See how good I feel.
Universal sign.
These are all old.
And with this approach,
it really doesn't matter why they're
doing hot rolled looks horrible,
grass overgrown or is a nice high
highway.
As long as the update that we can learn
from it currently not used anymore than
our campus.
So that's just the ideal.
What experimenting.
Oh,
cool.
So the noises in the background but not
acting.
This is actually real.
We struggle so much to get this to work
for.
An important deadline was just about 12
hours before the drop dead deadline that
those things started working.
That was a big relief.
So this is um,
uh,
a made up construction side but on paved
section in the,
in about,
uh,
people often ask 12,
if you train this in California,
can he drive in New Jersey?
So we,
we showed it here,
we trained with California data only on
a new Chelsea highway and he had at
night please linked slightly on an
unpaved road in a nearby park.
Got It.
So we'll move on to something a little
more practical.
This is highway driving.
Um,
so he had been driving,
you'll see here,
you see this is what the network
protects,
what the human would drive and you see
that line markings here are lousy and
then in part they're completely missing.
And that doesn't seem to impress the
netvault keep people,
they still protects,
protects the correct trajectory.
What do you see here is we show the
trajectory is predicted from the most
recent 10 frames and then correct them
for Iga motion of the car.
And then he showed them all on top of
each other.
This is a debugging tool.
Um,
if the network is confident,
it will be consistent with its
predictions over a few frames and the
noodles are nice and tight.
And if it's not confidence,
then they'll spread out all over the
place.
It will predict something different each
flame.
So he had not to try taking,
take to the exit,
uh,
or here again,
this is all stuff that we haven't
programmed.
They just picked it up by observing
humans.
Um,
we're not limited to,
to La on lane keeping.
We can also learn lane changes.
So this is a video showing that the,
the lane changes or triggered manually
by a,
this is change and here driving and he's
uh,
he's just taping the Labor for the turn
signal and that's,
that indicates to the corner they should
now change lanes.
We can also learn different,
uh,
length of the lane changes.
So we can tell the car to do complete
the lane change and two meters or 100
meters or 50 meters.
That's actually quite exciting.
Uh,
I tie waist speeds,
completing lane change and 50 meters.
We can also allow him to take,
this was particularly exciting because
I'm not sure that's really any other
ways you should do this.
Well,
I know if I wasn't he cuddled goals is
to be able to send the car okay.
By fame,
I would go back to the office.
Okay.
So one of the things I mentioned before
that,
uh,
it's important that,
or an important aspect of our work is to
learn by observing humans,
not by manually programming things into
the system,
but nevertheless,
they want to understand what it actually
learned.
So he'll be analyzed what,
what is looking at this DC,
the green regions,
these are the regions that the network
is sensitive to and you see that it
learns to recognize that [inaudible]
Lane markings,
which is interesting because we never
labeled a single lane marking during
training or here in a residential
street.
He learns to look at the cars.
But if you look closely and you can the
trees here or on our campus,
if there's no clear lane markings,
it learns to figure it out to the
Dextero.
Dhs through other means.
Okay.
So this is an important,
a very important tool for us.
Here's a short video,
you'll see a line match.
So about the driving on the highway,
it's looking at both land markings,
but this one will disappear in a moment.
And now instead of looking at the bowls
of a doubly wide lane is actually just
following this one until the right one
comes close enough so it becomes a
single lane again.
And it picked that up by observing.
This is not us manually programming that
into the system.
Um,
at one point some day we needed a
screenshot from the inside of the car
and there's a lot of construction going
on on the campus currently.
And bobcat comes out into our old way.
And if you look here,
the network,
uh,
prominently recognizes it even though
we're quite soft and it's never seen
this type of vehicle in the training
before.
Yeah.
So I wanted to close with,
uh,
some open challenges.
My mind,
these are,
while we have tons of open challenges,
but these are two of the big ones.
One is to deal with ambiguous
situations.
So if you imagine any won't allow them
to merge onto a highway and you have a
car right next to you,
then you can either speed up and go in
front or it can slow down and go behind
what he can do,
the average.
So how would we,
how would we deal with that hobby?
Can learn from that as more than one
possible,
a correct way of driving,
but you're only ever get one,
one,
one of these possible options in each
example.
And then the other one is learned from
imperfect behavior.
So we have a ton and ton of data,
but currently we need to cut out all the
imperfect driving.
You don't want to teach the network to
cutting corners and such.
Okay.
And Andy Dazzler on multiple,
what do you do?
So it may makes the humans,
so if we can get around and figured out
how he can learn on its own,
what it actually should look at and
Modis for dot outliers,
we would have a ton more data that we
can work with them.
And so I will finish with this video
here.
Uh,
this was recorded recently in December.
We got new data from a new sensor set of
a new car fleet.
And so the first 10 hours came in all
California data in the sun,
very little night,
no rain.
And so the first thing they usually do
is we train and networks.
We go out and test to see if it meets
our expectations.
This is kind of an end to end test to
see,
to make sure that nothing's wrong with
this new data.
Uh,
that day it happened to snow.
So we were curious to see what happens
and it actually is,
uh,
performed.
Surprisingly.
My also all this network has ever seen
is California data and is now driving in
the snow and no Chelsea or here at
night,
uh,
on a potluck snow covered road was a
lights from oncoming traffic.
Okay.
You can also see what it's looking at
and it,
it looks at what seems correct on the
road here.
It even looks at the tread of the tire
tread markings in this now even though
it certainly hasn't seen that in,
uh,
in the original training data.
And that brings me to the end.
Thank you for your attention.